[Aplausos]
[Música]
chamanes magos brujos y hechiceros buena
parte de américa latina es una tierra de
viejas supersticiones una tierra de
celebración de rituales donde el sentido
mágico de la vida florece en todo su
esplendor
[Música]
amigos gracias a todo este despliegue de
fantasía y magia fue precisamente aquí
en latinoamérica donde a lo largo del
siglo 20 más se desarrolló el realismo
mágico una corriente artística donde los
mitos las leyendas la magia y la
fantasía se fusionan y se integran con
la realidad
[Música]
pero un momento vamos a ver puede que
alguno de vosotros esté preguntando si
me habré equivocado de canal por qué
diantres me hablan en visual político
del sentido mágico de la vida pues
porque todo esto no es algo que afecte
sólo a la cultura veréis en
latinoamérica este sentido mágico de la
vida tiene mucha influencia sobre muchos
elementos de la sociedad incluyendo la
política atentos el realismo mágico en
la política amigos a lo largo de la
historia en muchos países incluidos los
países europeos ha sido relativamente
habitual que los caciques los tiranos o
los monarcas absolutos trataran de
legitimar su poder de la mano de la
religión bueno ahora que lo pienso la
verdad es que esto no es tan antiguo ni
desde luego una cosa del pasado al fin y
al cabo es más o menos lo que está
haciendo vladimir putin en rusia con la
iglesia ortodoxa
[Música]
el caso amigos es que todo esto es algo
muy parecido a lo que han hecho y hacen
algunos caudillos latinoamericanos en
este caso utilizando no solo la religión
sino también las tradiciones las
supersticiones y las creencias populares
para que pues para legitimarse en el
poder o reforzar un discurso populista
claro vamos a ver si una forma de hacer
política no funciona pues algo se
tendrán que sacar de la manga nos parece
en algunas ocasiones todo esto ha
supuesto construir realidades que están
a medio camino entre la verdad y la
fantasía o incluso revestir al líder con
poderes sobrenaturales en el cielo no
nos dejes caer en la tentación del
capitalismo
de la maldad de la oligarquía claro que
todo esto no suele ser más que un
hechizo un hechizo cuya finalidad en la
mayoría de los casos pasa por consolidar
el poder de algún que otro tirano al fin
y al cabo ya lo sabes la magia da
seguridad explica lo que no se entiende
racionalmente y arregla lo que de otra
manera no se consigue pero un momento
tenéis algunos ejemplos pues ahí tenemos
el caso de françois duvalier un dictador
que durante 14 años gobernó haití a
través de la violencia y el vudú sí sí
con el vudú
françois duvalier fue un salvaje tirano
que se autocalificó como un jungla es
decir como un sacerdote vudú como un
chamán que hacía rituales de lo más
extraños y que trataba de imitar al
barón sandy ni más ni menos que el señor
de los cementerios en la tradición vudú
para tratar de hacerse pasar por una
encarnación de él así es de repente el
tirano se convirtió en el señor de la
muerte duval y creó su propia milicia
conocida como los tonton macoutes el
nombre de un ogro del folclore haitiano
algo así como el hombre del saco
reclutando generalmente en las cárceles
a unos perfiles muy adecuados para su
propósito de servir al señor de la
muerte asesinos ladrones y todo tipo de
delincuentes que se dedicaron
salvajemente a mantener a raya a la
población del país
qué mejor forma de mantener las cosas
bajo un control nos parece en fin otro
ejemplo tal vez un poco menos folclórico
pero no por ello menos intenso sea el de
venezuela por un lado tras la muerte de
hugo chávez desde el régimen se trató de
conferirle de darle una cierta categoría
de divinidad para ello se llegaron a
montar altares e incluso se modificó el
padrenuestro la oración católica por
excelencia por él chávez nuestro que
estás en los cielos fijaos chávez
nuestro que estás en el cielo en la
tierra en el mar y en nosotros los y las
delegadas santificado sea tu nombre
venga a nosotros tu legado para llevarlo
a los pueblos de aquí y de allá y luego
también estuvo la historia del pajarito
sirve y yo también de responder silbido
el pajarito le dio una vuelta y se fue y
yo sentí que ya estaban en tu vida
canciones del comandante para esta
batalla
pajarito le hace un pío pío y maduro
interpreta que le ha dicho hoy comienza
la batalla revolucionario con lo cual
maduro es un traductor de los cantos de
los pajaritos pero no sólo eso por otro
lado como muestra de toda esta fusión de
realidad y fantasía tenemos también la
instrumentalización de simón bolívar o
la narración de la guerra económica algo
así como el resto del mundo tiene a
venezuela en la diana y quiere su
destrucción pero nosotros no nos
rendiremos sin embargo como ya os hemos
contado aquí en visual político en un
montón de vídeos los problemas que tiene
venezuela se deben básicamente a las
políticas de la revolución bolivariana
pero continuemos
otro caso lo encontramos en nicaragua
por ejemplo en rosario murillo
vicepresidente primera dama y compañera
inseparable de daniel ortega con las
manos repletas de piedras turquesas para
espantar la mala suerte sus discursos
son una especie de cóctel entre
espiritualidad religiosidad y política
y desde luego no es nada extraño
escuchar en sus discursos términos como
bendición prodigio milagros o arengas
como nicaragua cristiana socialista y
solidaria todo claro con el objetivo de
levantar el fervor popular y mostrar
algo así como una realidad dopada una
realidad donde las políticas del régimen
de repente adquieren una enorme
trascendencia pero ojo no es que lo diga
yo atentos a la propia rosario murillo
atentos la vida es una comedia la
política en el mundo se ha convertido en
un circo apunte monos a ser los magos
del circo rosario murillo os habéis dado
cuenta al final no es más que una forma
de hacer populismo para mantener el
poder y también para llenarse los
bolsillos pero oye qué narraciones más
apasionantes no os parece lástima que
luego la realidad sea tan diferente y
amigos que os parece si echamos un
vistazo precisamente la realidad de lo
que el rosario murillo calificada de
patria bendita católica socialista y
solidaria atentos
[Música]
el hechizo
nicaragua un país que parece condenado a
sufrir dictadura tras dictadura vive una
enorme crisis política la represión del
gobierno contra las protestas típicas
que reclaman más democracia y libertad
se han saldado con la pérdida de más de
300 300 vidas
[Música]
os hemos hablado ya de ello aquí en
visual polític desde donde enérgicamente
hemos condenado la violencia ejercida
por el régimen de daniel ortega claro
que el rosario murillo no lo ve de la
misma forma según ella lo que ocurre en
nicaragua es que la patria bendita sufre
una invasión de espíritus malignos que a
ojo no son los que ejerce la violencia o
meten la mano en las arcas públicas sino
los que buscan acabar con el desmedido
poder de ella y su marido claro
[Música]
y ojo amigos porque la señora murillo
sabe muy bien de lo que habla la otra
vida y el maligno no son secretos para
ella fijaos desde que la familia
ortega-murillo retornó al poder en el
año 2007 cada cinco años cuando se
celebran elecciones todas las sospechas
apuntan a que miles y miles de personas
fallecidas salen de sus tumbas y se
encaminan a votar por supuesto por
daniel ortega ya sabéis un clásico del
fraude electoral y ojo porque nicaragua
los muertos no sólo votan y en algunos
casos también se presentan a las
elecciones sí sí tal cual como lo
escucháis nicaragua el país donde los
muertos pueden ser electos
investigaciones denuncian listas de
candidatos electorales pereña das con
nombres de difuntos por cierto sabéis
que respondió el consejo supremo
electoral supuestamente el órgano
responsable de velar por el buen
funcionamiento de las elecciones cuando
hubo quejas por todas estas apariciones
atentos investigar si son ciertos o no
son ciertos los candidatos si existen o
no existen si están vivos o no están
vivos si están en el cielo o en la
tierra no es facultad legal del cs
consejo supremo
vamos fraude fraude fraude pero ahora
bien si en nicaragua las personas que ya
no están en este mundo pueden votar y
presentarse a las elecciones porque no
van a poder trabajar a ver por qué pues
eso es precisamente lo que debió
preguntarse daniel ortega cuando en 2016
falleció
rené núñez el presidente de la asamblea
nacional en el congreso de nicaragua
veréis según la ley y el sentido común
el presidente fallecido debería haber
sido sustituido por un nuevo sin embargo
no nada de eso el plenario formado
básicamente por diputados afines al
gobierno decidió mantenerla en el puesto
una temporada más
un muerto preside el parlamento de
nicaragua rené núñez leal operador del
presidente daniel ortega y fallecido el
10 de septiembre es nombrado presidente
de la asamblea nacional vamos que
nicaragua es el país donde los muertos
además de votar y presentarse a las
elecciones también aprueban leyes y
macabros ahora bien puede que alguno de
vosotros esté preguntando pero enrique
que saca la familia ortega murillo con
todas estas cacicadas seguro que la
inmensa mayoría ya os lo imagináis pero
por si acaso hagamos un repaso a esta
particular familia
a nicaragua en su cortijo particular
y debe trabajar
dejando a un lado la ficción
amigos nicaragua es uno de los países
más pobres de américa latina' la renta
per cápita apenas supera los dos mil
dólares anuales y la pobreza afecta a
casi una de cada tres personas por
supuesto la situación de la familia
ortega murillo es muy pero que muy
diferente claro que en esta ocasión no
me voy a referir a su patrimonio sino a
cómo utilizan el presupuesto público a
su antojo empecemos por ejemplo con
laureano ortega uno de los hijos del
presidente daniel ortega fijaos el bueno
de laureano trabaja para el gobierno
como asesor de la agencia de promoción
de inversiones pronicaragua y es
conocido por ser un gran coleccionista
de relojes rolex ya sabéis nicaragua
católica socialista y solidaria
pero no sólo esto laureano es un tipo
con gusto así que con fondos del
gobierno del gobierno de uno de los
países más pobres de latinoamérica se ha
montado su propio festival de ópera
cuestión de prioridades que por supuesto
le cuesta un buen pico a todos los
nicaragüenses
también tenemos a camila ortega una
joven que quería ser modelo como no lo
consiguió que pensáis que hizo pues sí
le pidió dinero a papá para montar
nicaragua diseña un evento al estilo de
la new york fashion week' todo con
dinero público en un país donde una de
cada tres personas vive con menos de
tres dólares al día pero claro que el
lujo ver a diseñadores y modelos
internacionales realizando pasarelas y
cócteles en los mejores hoteles y
centros de convenciones del país
nicaragua católica socialista y
solidaria ahora bien de qué sirven las
pasarelas y los festivales de ópera si
no son convenientemente promocionados
por los medios de comunicación pues no
no os preocupéis no hay ningún problema
el señor ortega lo tiene todo bajo
control tiene a sus otros hijos
liderando cinco canales de televisión y
múltiples radios todas claro favorecidas
por el gobierno ya sabéis hay que
impulsar la industria audiovisual es una
industria estratégica
pues bien entre estos otros hijos
metidos a magnates de los medios de
comunicación está el bueno de juan
carlos un tipo que además de dirigir la
agencia que se encarga de la publicidad
del gobierno también aspira a dar el
salto al mundo del cine de hecho entre
sus proyectos estuvo la producción de
una película una especie de comedia para
adultos con algún rombo y bastante mal
gusto que el gobierno de nicaragua
decidió financiar con más de 400 mil
dólares
lástima que la película no tuvo el éxito
esperado y apenas logró recaudar tres
mil dólares sobre juan carlos y ya por
último tenemos a rosario murillo ya
sabéis la de nicaragua católica
socialista y solidaria
[Música]
pues bien el caso es que rosario decidió
gastarse bueno mejor dicho gastar del
presupuesto público en este caso de la
empresa pública de electricidad varios
millones de dólares en decenas y decenas
de enormes árboles de metal que además
cuestan una pasta en mantenimiento los
árboles de la vida imprescindibles
prioritarios para el desarrollo del país
festivales de ópera pasarelas de moda
películas empresas de medios los árboles
de la vida caprichos todos ellos pagados
con dinero de todos los nicaragüenses y
luego ya aparte por supuesto todas las
sospechas de corrupción y malversación
de fondos públicos
amigos esta es la realidad esto es lo
que se esconde tras la ficción
construida por políticos que tratan de
legitimar con fantasías lo que no pueden
hacer con resultados
así es como muchos caudillos como daniel
ortega han convertido a sus países en
auténticas haciendas privadas para su
propio beneficio pero ahora la pregunta
que podemos hacernos es podrán los
nicaragüenses romper el hechizo del
sandinismo conseguirán librarse de este
corrupto violento y represivo régimen
déjame la respuesta en los comentarios y
también en esta encuesta si te ha
resultado interesante el vídeo dale a
like y no olvides suscribirte a visual
político un saludo y hasta la próxima
el pajarito le hace un pío pío y maduro
interpreta que le ha dicho hoy comienza
la batalla revolucionaria con lo cual
maduro es un traductor de los cantos de
los pajaritos